you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui c'est
que ça aujourd'hui on se retrouve de
nouveau pour une petite compilation de
jeux parce que je trouvais sur pas mal
de jeux qui ont l'air vraiment bizarre
notamment celui ci le jeu s'appelle kids
the cat trouve le chat est ce que c'est
déjà la fin du jeu trouve le char at
home et c'est ridicule cet objectif quoi
oui ok ok il s'était déporté d'accord
[ __ ] téléportation spectaculaire oui
du petit chat il est là comme je les ai
retrouvés au nom il se téléporte à l'été
les portes toi voilà maintenant je vais
bien me garder en charge jours qu'on
attendait mais ça va être ça pendant mon
dieu ah ouais t'as je me disais ça va un
moment les conneries ok je trouve tes
amis regardez moi ça [ __ ] c'est
carrément chauloux quoi une sorte de
totem en châle un papier à la boîte
c'est une trottinette
allez on s'éclate salut copains je suis
l'homme à la trottinette chars
m'aimes-tu hommes et non mais pourquoi
tout le monde me filmer quoi mais c'est
un [ __ ] de cache cache quoi simulateur
de cache cache et en quoi c'est un ami
[ __ ] ils étaient deux méchants avec le
manger ta dans l'ombre des ruines sorte
de girafes avec des oreilles de shrek
c'est un peu sexy salut je suis sexy tu
veux être mon copain très bien je m'en
vais mais je vous promets que soit la
miniature cd ça je me suis dit en outre
aux mignot téléchargé je n'aurais jamais
dû jouer xavi tu howie intellipoint
monde je dois trouver quoi trouver des
pissenlits et c'est bon à mon dieu c'est
le dieu des sharks à la fin du jeu j'ai
peur quoi mais non mais c'est une sorte
de tabou région en fête
or quel film quel film
ziad mais non vous rigolez ses aveux je
suis désolé de vous avoir montré ce jeu
voilà je m'excuse pour faire pardonner
je vous propose qu'on se rende en fait
c'est parti on aime attention aux
parties une sorte de simulateur de fait
un donc j'entends de la musique
effectivement
est ce que je peux dire qu'il ya une
ambiance de fou ici oh oui ça discute
dans le garage
qu'est-ce qu'ils gardent un oeil à quoi
à la télé d'accord gi oh là là mais ils
sont carrément train de phase et
regardez moi ça tu changeras de chemise
1 il ya plus de place à côté de toi donc
est-ce que je peux m'asseoir sur tes
genoux et éventuellement qui ne
répondent pas qu'on sent ça j'adore
cette règle étoiles à qui tu attends
c'est peyrefitte là les jumeaux 1 j'ai
vu clair dans votre petit jeu là bon
allez dégagez je venais jouer dans le
garage bonjour les autres ce que vous
salut comment ça se passe ici face aux
tweets food
vous n'avez plus fin ok mais qu'ils
mangent et le succès le plus fin ça
marche qu'est ce qu'on a ici non j'ai vu
clair dans notre petit jeu les types les
mai mai après problèmes plus tard c'est
tous des consanguins c'est pas possible
sans déconner alors qu'est ce que c'est
que ça va pas se servir de la bière bon
bah je m'en vais voilà et j'en profite
au passage j'ai pas fin attendue lors
jamais france mec a alors ça c'est un
pont bir je crois bien un gf100 vous
avoir déjà vu ses vents bizarre eux
oh oui aux animations trop stylé au
ralenti à banos attendait mais ça c'est
des poches de derrière tontine est
complètement à l'envers monsieur
d'accord donc le même effectivement a bu
quelques bières au lalano battant il
femme assassinée quoi il veut se mettre
va partir sur un commun en fait je joue
aux boules byrs mais que dans un sens y
accueille qui jette la balle moi
j'achète pas la balle il m'a bien
défoncé un il faut que je mange
j'ai pas fort mais j'aurais jamais fait
face aux jumeaux mourir de faim
finalement ok j'ai un gobelet que je
tiens à l'horizontale beer pong je
comprends pas comment on joue mais au
jour mais c'est insupportable ce jeu
j'ai abandonné je suis désolé du coup
maintenant je me retrouve à prendre
plein de bière là pour vous essayer
d'oublier ce moment difficile vous
m'aimez pas banon vous êtes deux groupes
de trois et moi je suis un groupe de 2 1
2 2 avec ce gobelet qui sera bientôt à
la poubelle je suis si bien avec mon
bidon de aulas alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé j'apparais dans une chambre avec
des habits par terre ne me dites pas que
cet homme à pécho
j'espère au moins que c'était pas le mec
qu'a pas de me défoncer au beer pong non
non non j'en avais son pantalon vert je
pense pas qu'il ait un soutien gorge en
fait j'ai sélectionné que des jeux
vraiment nul que la vidéo va s'appeler
jeu pourri et je me suis en temps pour
le jeu qu'on va tester maintenant qui
est en fait un simulateur d'ouverture du
feu babybel de cheesy belle part dans
les emails regarder un peu ce gameplay
futuriste ce gameplay incroyable
révolutionnaire on a ouvert le baby beel
fin du jeu voilà je suis pas ce que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui quand j'ai sélectionné
ces jeux mais [ __ ] je devais aller
très mal
et qu'est ce que c'est que ça simulateur
de clips non mais c'est vraiment un
simulateur de kapla oh non mais non il
serait 1000 boul
alléluia logiquement je suis un humain
attendant je peux peut-être volé en fait
à d'accord c'est une caméra
bon voilà c'est pas mal d'être une
caméra finalement on peut faire plein de
choses notamment fuir fuir ce jeu c'est
incroyable c'est un jeu triple à
c'est une révolution dans le gaming oh
non je veux jouer à ce jeu je veux jouer
à ce jeu
après les caps là les cartes ça me
ferait trop plaisir rien bon assez doit
aussi bien modélisés s'il vous plaît à
la dépression aujourd'hui la caisse et
que tous ces jeux vita
alors ok j'ai un balai et je nettoie le
sol c'est génial on a déjà fait une
vidéo sur un simulateur de ménage
finalement et là c'est exactement la
même chose en dix fois plus pixelisé
c'est génial
aux saluts un peu d'amour aujourd'hui
tient acheté les toiles à face et me
regarde le ménage sans rien dire sans
bouger
regardez regardez comme il est père
fille de cet homme permet pas et je m'en
vais laporte a l'air verrouillé mais
c'est sérieux mais je te déteste toi oh
oui j'ai trouvé un jeu qui va relever le
niveau
une terrible simulation de vélo aulas
est un jeu nul en temps normal avec et
avec les jeux auxquels on ajoute juste
avant je pense qu'il va me paraître
tellement bien ce parti installer le
joueur aux [ __ ] larnack c'est pour
vous et l'intérêt de bien puisque c'est
vous qui me l'avait conseillé nouvelle
qu'avant des excuses aux mais non [ __ ]
mec va être tellement content que avoir
la notification un gros coup à acheter
votre jeu est-ce que cet achat est pour
vous c'est un cadeau c'est un cadeau
j'ai trouvé ça pour moi quand même assez
pour moi c'est l'heure de lancer ce jeu
je compte sur vous pour ne rien faire
j'avoue avoir perdu menu est ce que est
ce que ça or les directs de dents au nom
ça c'est interdit de faire ça te mettre
à l'écriture pixelisé dans le décor la
digos ride georges abattant est-ce qu'on
va réussir à sauter là dessus maintenant
aller amusons-nous je viens d'acheter le
jeu mais détail pénale sur lui-même
kouao we are marshall ayari magnifique
comme on tourne mais c'est bien beau de
sauter moi je me déplace au soutien pas
de problème je m'en vais mais je m'en
fous ou appelez au pelage ans j'en ai
même fait mes potes sur le caillou au
jeu pédales j'aime le vélo et normand
attention roue arrière il reste comme ça
à l'arrêt il tourne comme ça y'a aucun
problème
moi je suis un coup son vélo il n'y a
pas de problème même si je suis un peu
plus blasés de la planète qu'est ce que
je fais là je vais lui tu te tais tu
fais du vélo et du coup on peut
hopley a way attend c'est l'accident
arrête de te la péter
ta salopette remy et voilà c'est tout
pour nous attend on va tenter va tenter
de passer là dessus ouais ouais ouais
c'est pas mal mais c'est 6 6 passes mais
sans voix calme en attelage j'hallucine
elle ya aujourd'hui je crois vraiment
qu'ils aient un sort qui s'abat sur nous
le sort appelé sort du jeu pourri ça va
très bien maintenant il est temps
d'arrêter ce carnage voilà j'espère
qu'avec la vidéo vous aura plu c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas le mais ça fera
vraiment plaisir que nicolas tu vas nous
manquer un tu faisais très bien du vélo
mais c'est triste
voilà voilà cette bosse verte va te
remplacer up mes sincères excuses moi je
m'en vais faire nicolas au carmel
cordialement je suis mes souffrances